and a Black Swan there's a turkey that  is fed every day by Butcher and every  day confirms to the turkey that the  turkey statistical Department to the  turkeys you know policy wonks to the  Turkish office and management and budget  that the butcher loves turkeys with  increased statistical confidence every  day  and that goes on for a long time there  is a day in November  when it's never a good idea to be a  turkey which is T minus two we call it  all right Thanksgiving one is two days  all right so what happens they're going  to be a surprise  it's going to be a Black Swan a large  surprise event but it would be a Black  Swan for the turkey not a Black Swan for  the butcher  okay there we go this is a turkey story  and my whole idea from the turkey story  to explain my Black Swan problem which  was misinterpreted for five years is the  whole idea is Let's Not Be turkeys  that's the whole point of the Black Swan